A couple of days ago, I was invited to a digital
viewing of Elden Ring.
It included new screenshots, the opportunity
for Q&A..but most importantly..I got to view
a stunning 16 minute gameplay showcase that..I'm
not allowed to show you for some reason?
It's weird, because the showcase was really
well made..so I assume you'll see it soon?
Until then, you have this video, which will
mainly be audio only
..so hey, while you listen, feel free to tab
out and browse Soul Arts, my art book project,
now on Kickstarter..
The first thing the player does, is approach
a Grace checkpoint.
For those of you who don't know, these are
Elden Ring's version of bonfires..but there's
more:
Because the open world is so vast, a gentle
ray of light will shine from the grace, pointing
you towards your next main objective.
To be clear, this doesn't mean your next objective
will be easy - so it might be wise to ignore
the guidance sometimes, and strike out on
your own path, looking for loot.
At points of lost Grace you can summon the
firekeeper maiden of this game..who I got
to see in a cutscene.
She phases in like a spirit, sits down, and
removes her hood - revealing light strawberry
blonde hair, and olive eyes - one of them
scarred and shut tight.
She introduces herself as "Melina", and offers
you an accord, ending the cutscene.
She's an S-tier maiden character.
You'll see.
In my interview it was revealed that you can
level up at Melina, and customise things like
your spirit summons, and equipped weapon skills,
while sitting at the Grace.
Graces also refill this game's equivalent
of an Estus Flask, but since they're are a
bit harder to come by than Bonfires, you can
also get a bit of health back by defeating
mobs of enemies, which From Software says
should keep you exploring a little bit longer.
Beyond Graces, there is another, more traditional
hub location..I'm showing it onscreen now.
Here, NPC's you meet in the outside world
will come to visit you, similar to places
like Firelink Shrine.
In the center is what looks like a Grace checkpoint,
right?
Except it's larger, with threads connected
to weapons lying askew in the middle of the
table.
Perhaps, every time you find a grace in the
outside world, a new thread is added?
Around the table are chairs, presumably where
NPC's will come to sit..
..and the room is very visually distinct from
other hubs we've seen before - It's ornate
and elegant, as befits a Tarnished, a character
who is striving to get this sort of dignity
back.
I love it.
After leaving the Grace, the character starts
running and summons their mount while moving
with a smooth, fast animation.
It's easy to imagine this being used mid-combat,
whenever you need a burst of speed to get
away, or close a gap.
Once you see the player actually riding around..you
get a thrill.
The previous trailer was great, but it was
cut so often that you couldn't get a sense
of the vastness of the world.
In this video, you get to see the player transition
from exploring that open world into exploring
camps, dungeons, and random encounters around
the place.
So, this video, unsurprisingly, reveals a
ton of new information.
During the presentation, From Software made
it clear that, generally, you might prefer
to fight on horseback against larger foes
where hit and run tactics are effective, and
dismount to take out multiple enemies more
carefully.
Out of combat, you and your horse have a sprint
that doesn't use up your stamina.
This will help you traverse the world.
In combat, however, stamina will come back
into play.
On horseback, you can easily fire arrows,
fire off sorcery, and of course, swing your
weapon.
I was shown horseback combat in a fight against
this giant wyvern, which starts as a small
speck in the sky, then flies down and obliterates
a mob of hollows standing nearby.
From software are calling these Field Bosses,
minibosses varying in difficulty that can
be fought in the open world.
The second field-boss in the trailer is fought
at the end of a co-op showcase, and fights
similarly to those dragonkin in archdragon
peak.
When they defeat this field boss, it leaves
a grace checkpoint behind, which I found interesting.
At some point in the trailer, the player brings
up the map..which has a very hand-drawn style,
and looks absolutely gorgeous.
One of the most interesting things I noticed
was an enormous ocean area, with ships and
even what looked like a path demarcated on
it.
It made me wonder if some sort of ocean exploration
is possible.
Your location and direction facing are shown
on the map, and From Software mention you
can set markers to help with exploration - for
example, taking note of a forest that might
contain crafting ingredients, or places with
a dangerous enemy you haven't yet defeated.
Marked areas on the map show up as pillars
of light in the distance, helping you move
towards them.
You don't fill out your map by exploring,
instead, you collect map fragments that are
scattered around the world.
They're clearly trying to build out their
loot tables here, to encourage dungeon diving.
Finally, once you've discovered a location,
you can easily fast-travel there.
It's a big step up from Sekiro's world map,
which was pretty useless.
However, Elden Ring is drawing heavily from
what they learned with Sekiro - adding a jump
button, and stealth, which play a huge part
in differentiating this game from Dark Souls.
The next section of the trailer has the player
dismount on a cliff.
They pull out their binoculars, and scout
out an enemy camp below, planning their assault.
To complement their stealth, something called
"sleep arrows" have been added, which allow
you to quietly incapacitate enemies from a
distance, giving you an opportunity to sneak
past without having to kill them.
The character does a killing blow on a sleeping
enemy, then attacks another enemy below them
with a jumping attack, which breaks their
guard and allows for another killing blow.
If that doesn't seem overpowered enough, you
can attack midair, you can shoot your bow
mid-air..you're basically Sekiro wearing armour.
Both Sekiro and Dark Souls had combat arts..but
in my opinion, neither Sekiro or Dark Souls
got weapon arts right.
However, Elden Ring just might.
In this game they're called "Skills", and
they're like weapon arts that can be assigned
to any weapon.
In this trailer, the character performs wind
blasts from a scimitar, and a thunder strike
from a polearm.
I think this will help your character feel
really custom.
Again, you probably find these hidden around
the world, adding to the loot table in the
game
Another set of things you can find hidden
around the world are "Spirits of the Deceased",
items that unlock different sets of NPC's
for summoning.
These can only be summoned in difficult areas
that have these obelisks present.
Some are tanky, some are aggressive, some
are ranged..and some come as a swarm of helpers.
In one example from the video, the player
summoned a set of like 6 friendly NPC's.
These phantoms caused chaos, allowing the
player to weave in and out of all the enemies
they were facing, dealing damage more freely.
I'd also like to mention..they were wielding
a twinblade in this scene.
I'm so glad they're bringing this back from
Dark Souls 2.
According to From Software, spirit summons
use the FP system you'll remember from Dark
Souls.
Stronger summons use more FP, and weaker summons
use less.
This might make it a bit less less overpowered
than I thought at first?
Since if you summon spirits, you might not
have access to your spells and skills.
Still, spirit summons are probably very powerful
by nature, and I anticipate Elden Ring in
general will be far more accessible to new
players, because of things like this.
A few sections of the video showcase co-op,
and this is something I'm really excited for,
because it seems less..instanced?
Than in previous games.
In the video, two players sneak through the
forest you see in this screenshot, avoiding
large, terrifying enemies who were patrolling
the area.
Later, we delve into an underground dungeon
with our partner, avoiding sen's fortress
style traps and ambushes together.
From Soft have previously mentioned that they
want to reduce the friction required for co-op,
removing requirements like having humanity
or embers..and I hope they take this all the
way, and make it easy to bring our friends
into our world, and keep them there.
I did notice that after defeating a field
boss, the partner didn't seem to disappear.
Finally, we make our way to "Stormvale Castle",
the Legacy dungeon of this first open world.
If the open world of Elden Ring is Dark Souls
with a horse, then Legacy dungeons are Dark
Souls with a jump.
From what I saw, they're WAY more vertical
than before, with multiple paths sprawling
left and right, and layered up and down.
Our character talks to an NPC as soon as they
arrive, and the NPC recommends we take the
back way into the castle.
The player, however, opts for the main gate
instead..and is instantaneous shot down by
ballista arrow fire.
I'm sure it's possible to roll through this,
but our player quickly changes their mind,
and takes the back way instead.
The back way through the castle has more Sekiro
elements - you use jumps to get over rubble,
avoid guards that signal the alarm, and use
sleep arrows to sneak past giant enemies.
Waiting for you at the end is the heavily
armed demigod, whose full intro cinematic
we get to see.
One of the cool things I noticed here was
a new sort of counter attack animation that
can be performed after blocking.
It's this one, from the earlier trailer.
Basically, when you block an attack in Elden
Ring with a weapon, it seems like you can
quickly follow up with a unique attack animation.
I love this idea.
In Dark Souls, it was usually always a terrible
idea to block with your weapon, as the stamina
and chip damage was super high..but now, in
Elden Ring, at least there's an offensive
benefit to blocking an attack like this.
It's not ideal, but it's not as punishing
as it used to be, either.
In conclusion, I take back what I said about
it not being big dark souls.
Elden Ring is kind of big Dark Souls.
But it's also Sekiro Souls, way more than
I expected, actually.
It really does seem like the culmination of
everything they've learned up to this point,
But before I go - would you guys listen to
an audiobook, if I narrated it?
I'm asking because..soon, you might have the
opportunity to.
A couple of weeks ago, I revealed our Kickstarter
for "Soul Arts", a premium art book filled
with the best art from the art competitions
I've been running the last few years.
It's also a book filled with short stories
on every page..and now, as a reward for all
the support you guys have given the project,
I'm planning on narrating the entire thing
for backers to enjoy on YouTube.
This is a new part of the digital edition
for the book, which almost all backers have
access to by default.
So please, enjoy "The Hinterlands", One of
many short stories I'm writing for Soul Arts.